well It Feels Like Only Yesterday we
were here with Fabiano handing him
another trophy in fact you know it was
more like nine rounds ago uh where he
won the St Louis rapid and Blitz Fabiano
congratulations on winning yet another
tournament singfield cup uh I just have
one question because I know they're
going to talk to you in studio and my
question is you going to leave any
trophies for anybody else this year well
I think this year I did an Ali Resa
because it's exactly what he what he did
last year so I'm I'm very happy of
course it's uh more better than I could
have dreamed of it's it's an amazing
result for me well congratulations once
again thank
you oh oh that's how it
works what a beautiful
C you see that's the problem when you
don't allow the spectators into the
playing Hall you don't get this
thunderous Applause for a job
extraordinarily well done and as we we
wrap up our uh uh broadcast uh we're
going to get Fabby so I just want to
give a big shout out to the players
first of all and there we see our sell
Cup champion but also to thank the
people at the St Louis chess club
absolutely and Scholastic Center for all
of their work and making our job so easy
World Chess Hall of Fame for they're
hosting AB silver back silver back and